hey leute was glaubt jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut bevor wir einfach
noch ganz schön am 28.04 also in fünf
tagen kommt dieser wunderschönen
wörtlich genommen kommt dieser
wunderschöne match von mir raus schreibt
euch jetzt hinter die ohren und jetzt
kommen wir da auch anfangen sollte und
zwar habe ich mir für heute etwas ganz
besonderes überlegt was ist wirklich
schon sehr lange nicht mehr gab ich
glaube das letzte video dazu habe ich
vor sechs monaten gemacht ja ganz
einfach aus dem grund weil ich das ganze
irgendwie ein bisschen fragwürdig und
immer langweiliger empfunden haben und
mir das selber nicht mehr so viel spaß
gemacht hat und zwar geht es heute um
musicali kennt ja wahrscheinlich jeder
von euch oder noch keine ahnung ich weiß
sowieso nicht mehr auf das noch so ein
hype ist wie damals auf jeden fall hatte
ich ja früher auch mal ein musical die
account und ich musste wirklich sagen
ich habe auf diese musical jetzt
bestimmt fünf monate habe ich nicht mehr
drauf geguckt und ich habe wirklich
überhaupt keine ahnung was da so abgeht
aber ich habe jetzt gedacht weil ich
früher ja einige videos dazu gemacht
habe auch wirklich videos die sehr viele
leute gesehen haben ich glaube mein
meisten klickt das video hat irgendwas
damit zu tun finde ich echt krass und
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht komm tust
du doch mal den zuschauern den gefallen
weil ich jemand davon aus dass viele von
euch sowas gerne mal wieder sehen würden
und wir schauen einfach mal zusammen
rein ich bin gespannt ich habe absolut
keine ahnung was mich da erwartet wird
und ob das immer noch so aussieht wie
damals aber mal sehen ich muss halt
einfach so kurz vorweg sagen dass ich
mich überhaupt nicht mehr mit diesem
musical hype identifizieren möchte
einfach aus dem grund weil es total
talentlosigkeit ist natürlich gibt es
die ein oder andere ausnahme die
wirklich gut tanzen kann oder so was ich
dann wirklich einigermaßen cool finde
aber da ist wirklich so viel schrott
dabei und ja das finde ich dann einfach
nicht gut wenn sich leute da so viel
drauf einbilden dass hier auch musik
100.000 follower haben oder so muss ich
mal gesagt haben natürlich ist dieses
youtube-video jetzt auch nicht das
aufwendigste das weiß ich selber aber es
nimmt locker das fünffache in anspruch
wie sowas
und so geil dass post
deswegen würde ich sagen wir lieber gar
nicht lange ich setze mich mal auf diese
seite hier glaube ich heute mache ich
sehe das ganze über mein handy auf und
musical i startet jetzt gerade mal so
gut dass stoppen wir erst mal kurz das
ist obwohl ich gucke ich gucke dann ist
nun schminkt tutorial gut da kann ich
dann auch noch sagen ob man es jetzt auf
youtube macht oder böse kenne jetzt auch
egal also sowas respektiere ich voll so
ich geh jetzt einfach mal auf mein
profil und moment ich habe 189 1200
follower ich kann mich jetzt ganz daran
erinnern ob das gestiegen ist in letzter
zeit oder ob es nicht gestiegen ist mein
musicali account nennen sich alex klaws
alex wenn es jetzt fragt wieso heißt
also egal und das letzte musical i was
ich gepostet habe wann war das
hier kann man nicht sogar statistiken
sehen das müsste auf jeden fall so fünf
sechs monate her sein und zwar wollte
ich mit diesem musical die einfach mal
so ein bisschen ja diese szene aufs korn
nehmen ich gucke mir das mal kurz an was
ich da gemacht habe
[Musik]
was
und diese scheiße haben sich wirklich
72.500 19 leute angeschaut
paul oder so also an sich sieht das
eigentlich noch aus wie für hier das ist
mein lieblings music ally so von mir
selber können wir auch schon ewig nicht
mehr gesehen so und ich würde sagen ich
schaue jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
rum was wir hier so finden also dass
wein ich halt irgendwie ich könnte da
nicht vor sitzen und mir dass die ganze
zeit so angucken weiterträumen ich würde
es halt so nun unterhalten weil das weiß
wirklich halt überhaupt nichts wo ich
sage er cool so hier haben wir jetzt das
habe ich auch auf youtube gesehen und
zwar war das total irgendwie so ein
alien tanz ich habe allerdings keine
ahnung um was ist da genau ging deswegen
schaue ich jetzt hier mal rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ich glaube das muss ich auch auf
jeden fall machen so das sind dann halt
sachen da kann ich nicht so sagen das
ist sogar witzig warum
[Musik]
gut das ist mal ein sehr gutes beispiel
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht total
schlechtes jahr die beiden sind
natürlich auch hübsch und können sich
gut synchron bewegen aber im endeffekt
ist es doch seit zwei oder drei jahren
immer das gleiche da stehen zwei mädels
leben männer die fast gleich aussehen
und machen dann so oder so und so und so
und so und drehen sich dann einmal und
das war's und das schauen dann so viele
leute an so dass es keine ahnung warum
ist natürlich auch eure sache aber ich
kann es halt nicht nachvollziehen dass
mit dem stolz ist mir neu gut das war
jetzt wieder witzig aber halt also es
ist halt so tun das ist schon wieder
richtig lustig ist also es war ich sogar
das leicht mich jetzt auch online es
wäre jetzt hier ein gutes video für
meinen habe ich das von ich hab das
glaube ich gemacht musik ellis mit 0
likes genau das hier hat nämlich auch
nur leicht ich bin jetzt einfach
millionen auf die suche gegangen und
hier kann man diese bestenliste sehen
das war früher da war ich auch schon mal
drin das beste war ich war einmal war
ich das weiß ich noch ganz genau in
deutschland auf platz zwei für einen tag
dann gleich auch wieder raus aber da
habe ich mich wirklich sehr gefreut ist
allerdings auch schon so eineinhalb
jahre her gut wir haben jetzt hier lisa
und lena auf platz eins ich glaube die
sind das seit drei jahren durchgehend
auf platz eins kann das sein
28,6 millionen musiker liefern das ist
natürlich eine krasse ansage das finde
ich auch wirklich kreis gut da muss ich
jetzt
gar nicht unbedingt reinschauen ich gehe
mal hier auf weltweit und da sind die
aber gar nicht mehr werden
die loren gray kenne ich auch noch
ansonsten sind das glaube ich alles neue
namen ich schaue mir einfach mal
irgendwas an jetzt hier
[Musik]
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel sich das
angeschaut hat und dann jetzt daneben
das macht von den beiden geben die auch
fast gleich aussahen finde ich irgendwie
so nullen unterschied wo man jetzt
dazwischen differenzieren kann ja eben
schon gesagt es ist immer das gleiche so
er drehte dass man nicht jetzt sogar
echt witzig ich mache dazu jetzt auch
gleich 1 das könnt ihr euch nach diesem
video auf meinem user kelly account
anschauen alex klaws alex auf jeden fall
abchecken geht es hier immer noch in die
heute hier gibt es ganz viele neue
kategorien style essen tiere sport blog
gaming sodann habe ich jetzt noch die
kategorie steigend gefunden ich glaube
das bistum halt irgendwie unbekannte
leute zu fördern
jetzt habe ich hier gerade den rasmus
gefunden der ist wahrscheinlich so 20 25
jahre alt und wird gerne gummi
süßigkeiten durch die luft lebensstil
erreicht leute also ich muss ganz klar
sagen mit abstand der beste musical
musicians sich das nochmal der besten
user mit abstand das bin ganz klar ich
denke auf jeden fall da vielleicht kommt
irgendwie in den nächsten ein zwei
jahren noch mal ein musical online wer
weiß ansonsten lässt auf jeden fall die
daumen nach oben da wenn euch das video
gefallen hat und wenn ich vielleicht
irgendwann noch mal was dazu machen soll
gibt noch nach oben bei 10.000 bikes
oder so sehe ich dass wir da immer noch
lust drauf habe leute wir sind uns
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder direkt auf
jeden fall auch ins netz ab und ich
wünsche euch noch einen angenehmen tag
haut rein